[Music]
you have probably already watched a lot
of Disney movies but even if you claim
that you're the biggest Disney fan there
are some stories that you will never get
the chance to see and characters that
you will never meet we heard rumors
saying that the producers were working
on some really interesting projects
before they were cancelled stay tuned to
hear about what was supposed to happen
in Hercules - the Trojan War if you love
Disney as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you
ten Disney movies that were never made
Newt do in summer 2011 Newt was the
first Pixar movie that had to be
canceled gary reads from a seven-time
Academy Award winner for sound design
was going to direct a movie for the
first time according to him Newt was
going to be a good old-fashioned
romantic comedy he then told the story
of two newts who go on an adventure and
discover that finding a mate is never as
easy as it seems love it turns out is
not a science everyone seemed to be
ready to create a really successful new
movie but in 2010 it was still nowhere
to be seen it wasn't even until a year
later in 2011 that the studio had to
explain that they had taken Newt out of
their development schedule to give a
chance to their creative teams who work
on upcoming projects but according to
John Lasseter who works at Pixar
Animation in Walt Disney Studios there
was another reason why the project was
cancelled it was simply too similar to
another movie that was out in theaters
at that time Rio Disney had what it
takes to face the competition but it
seems like they just didn't want to play
this game but don't worry Newt might get
another chance Lasseter said that this
project is just on the shelf and they
will see where it goes in the future
this is why we should never say never
Swan Lake you have maybe heard of the
movie The Swan Princess it was not
produced by Disney but directed by a
former Disney animator director Richard
rich based on the ballet Swan Lake it
told the story of two children who had
to spend the summer together because
their parents hoped that they would fall
in love and their kingdoms would be
united Odette and Derek couldn't stand
each other but when they grew up they
started to see things in a different
light then one night Odette was
kidnapped and her prince wanted to save
her to prove that he was truly in love
with her unfortunately the movie was one
of the biggest animated box-office
disasters in history they made 9 million
dollars less than half of their budget
and just because they couldn't learn
from their mistakes the Swan Princess
was followed by six direct-to-video
sequels but it is rumoured that Disney
wanted to work on this story too and a
movie called The Swan Lake it means that
the beautiful Odette would have had the
chance to become a Disney Princess they
planned a more classic version of the
ballet but finally cancelled it before
another producer decided to work on this
story and it seems like Disney made the
right decision because people did not
want to see that movie after all shade
maker Disney can make mistakes too and
when they do it is actually really
expensive
in 2012 the producers lost 50 million
dollars when they decided to cancel a
film they were working on people
believed that it was the latest
stop-motion movie by Henry Selick who
also directed Coraline and The Nightmare
Before Christmas the filmmaker was
highly respected 150 animators were
working on this project and they had
already been working on it for two years
but it seems like it simply wasn't
enough to make the cut the film was
simply not coming together in a manner
that pleased the studio no one really
knows what the director had been working
on but according to a job posting the
movie was called shade makers and their
goal was to make great scary films for
young uns we don't know what is the
reason why Disney decided to give up
after spending 50 million dollars but it
was probably better than losing even
more money on a project that was not
going to work if you're curious to see
what shade maker is about you might get
the chance to see it one day it has been
reported that Henry Selick still has the
opportunity to approach other Studios
with his movie so someone else might
give him the money he needs to finish it
where the wild things are this is a
movie that we loved even though it was
not produced by Disney where the wild
things are told the story of a young boy
named Max who had a lot of imagination
after an incident he ran away from home
not only physically but also mentally in
a new world
this is where he met large wild beasts
who decided to take him as their king
the story was based on a 1963 children's
picture book by Maurice Sendak
it was so popular that it had already
been adapted into a short film and an
opera before being turned into a live
action movie in 2009 but did you know
that Disney wanted to work on this
fantasy drama film - in the 90s they
actually owned the rights for where the
wild things are director John Lasseter
was supposed to work on this fantastic
movie the background was going to be
done by computer and they wanted the
characters to be hand-drawn to make sure
that what makes Disney stand out
wouldn't be lost
however Disney saw that this idea was
too expensive at that time and they
decided to cancel the project they just
had time to do a test before they
realized that it was way too complicated
but we hoped that they would have
finished their project this story would
have been a little something more with
the magic of Disney The Legend of Aida
if you love musicals and Disney you will
love to hear more about elaborate lives
The Legend of Aida by Elton John and Tim
Rice it was Disney's first musical to be
built from scratch and they invested 20
million dollars in this project based on
an 1871 Verdi opera The Legend of Aida
told the story of a princess enslaved by
the Egyptians and a soldier among the
actors start a huge ever morphing
pyramid that transformed itself during
the show
unfortunately this thing kept breaking
down every night so the audience was
always a bit disappointed even though
the story had a lot of potential Disney
had already been known for great
Broadway hits like Beauty and the Beast
and The Lion King and it was a challenge
to work on a story that no one had ever
seen before but it is rumoured that
Disney actually wanted to see this story
on screen they worked on an animated
film before the production was shut down
in 1997 and their idea to make a
live-action movie about Aida didn't work
either
so that girl never got the chance to
become a Disney Princess but we think
that it is never too late if people like
the story on stage why not turn it into
a movie we think that this princess
deserves another chance swabbies
we see Mickey Mouse everywhere so it is
surprising to think that he was one day
rejected swabbies was an animated
feature Rhett directed by Daryl van
sitters that was supposed to be released
in 1989 in this new story Mickey Mouse
Donald Duck and Goofy were out of work
and they needed a job so they went to a
boot camp to be part of the Navy and
this is when they met their friends
Minnie Mouse Daisy Duck and Clarabelle
cow at that time this project was the
second of half-hour projects
Disney wanted their favorite classic
heroes to be back into the spotlight the
short film was already storyboarded
recorded and the team started working on
the animation but it never got completed
the fact that a new team was working
with a different type of paper and paint
to lower the costs probably didn't help
this project turned out to be more
complicated than they had imagined at
least new talent got the chance to work
for the first time with the Disney team
so the story isn't so bad after all
but we think that Daisy and Clarabelle
would deserve the opportunity to shine
too
we just wish that Disney could give
another chance to Mickey Mouse and his
friends it has been far too long since
we saw them in a movie The Rainbow Road
to Oz we all remember the Wizard of Oz
even though it was released in 1939 it
was still a must watch movie that our
parents wanted us to see in our
childhoods based on the elf frank Baum's
stories Dorothy and her dog Toto were
caught in a tornado and ended up in the
world of Oz looking for a wizard who
would help her come back home she met
many friends on her journey and this is
how the whole world fell in love with
this magical movie Disney saw that The
Wizard of Oz was a success and this is
probably why they wanted to be a part of
this universe too we know that Oz the
great and powerful was released in 2013
but since the 30s Disney had been
working on a similar project they tried
to acquire the rights to several
children's books but MGM ended up buying
the rights to the Wizard of Oz in 1937
so they decided to buy the rights to 11
other books in the Oz series instead
they started working on a live-action
movie called the Rainbow Road to Oz and
even released a preview we don't know
why the project was cancelled but people
believed that Disney was busy working on
their projects so unfortunately we will
never get the chance to see how Disney
would reimagine the world of Oz the
gremlins we have all seen the gremlins
movie from 1984 by Warner Brothers but
did you know that Disney had been
working on this project since the early
40s with Rahl doll the writer was
working on a kind of British propaganda
a story about creatures who sabotage the
plane during that time Disney was
looking for war related stories to
develop as films and this is how they
started working together they had at
least two screenplays written for this
project and planned to feature both
live-action and animation and also
animated short subjects they even
published a Disney Illustrated storybook
of the original story in anticipation of
the release of the film and the gremlins
appeared in many comic books but that's
all we had the chance to see at that
time as the film project was finally
cancelled Disney was not able to secure
the exclusive rights to the gremlins and
other studios were already working on
similar projects
moreover the RAF retained the copyright
to the gremlins and wanted to approve
the final script this is why Walt Disney
decided to give up thinking he wouldn't
have the chance to make enough money
with these characters however we are
lucky to finally see the gremlins 40
years later thanks to Warner Bros and it
is probably better this way
with the new technology gremlins was
better than what we could have imagined
at that time the rescuers if you've seen
this movie don't worry you're not crazy
it hasn't been canceled but there was
actually one really important character
that didn't make it to the big screen
and it was Louie the bear at that time
Walt Disney wanted to work on a story
based on Margery sharps novels about two
little mice on the way to a mission they
were supposed to meet a bear who would
help them free a little girl who had
been kidnapped penny the character is
voiced by Louis Prima and he had already
recorded many songs
unfortunately the voice actor discovered
that he had a brain tumor and went into
a coma shortly after he passed away
three years later the studio couldn't
find any actor who was better than him
to portray Louie the bear so they just
decided to completely delete the
character and change the story of the
film
the only thing they kept in the final
movie was the song the need to be loved
but the lyrics were changed - someone's
waiting for you and a new singer was
hired
but then in 2013 we had the chance to
hear one of the last songs that Louis
Prima ever recorded on blu-ray we can
see a brand new restoration of Louis
singing the song people itis this is how
the actor made everyone smile before he
went on his own journey and his voice
will stay in our hearts forever Hercules
to the Trojan War
yes you heard it right we were supposed
to see more of the Hercules universe in
1997 we had the chance to see the half
God half mortal on his journey to become
a true hero with the help of his friend
Pegasus and a personal trainer filled
the stator the movie was so popular that
it was followed by a less successful TV
series in 1998 Hercules zero to hero but
did you know that a second movie was in
the making - according to the rumor
Disney was working on Hercules - the
Trojan War an animated feature film that
was supposed to be released in 2001 in
this movie Hercules was living in Athens
with Megara and their daughter Phoebe
when one of his old friends Helen was
captured by Paris of Troy the hero
decided to join the Greek army with the
help of the gods in the Trojan horse
Hercules defeated his enemy but there
were more challenges waiting for him as
he ended up fighting with Cyclops being
seduced by mermaids and meeting the
sorceress Circe it would have been a
great story but unfortunately it never
made it to the big screen and not even
on to DVD if you could see one of these
ten canceled movies which one would it
be don't be shy tell us what you think
in the comment section down below and
that's it for 10 Disney movies that were
never made if you want to see more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
deleted Disney Princesses and rejected
concepts thank you so much for watching
and hey we'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]